make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and i'll be honest with you guys i
have not really been reading the savage
avengers and i know a lot of you guys
have suggested it a lot of you guys have
said that like savage avengers is a
really really really really really good
story
i read the first arc city of sickles
because i usually try to give every
single story that comes out like one
single story arc to see whether or not i
like it but then i kind of dropped off
after that and a lot of you guys said it
was amazing and you're like you need to
cover savage avengers or at least
read more of it and so we're going to
cover the king in black tie-in for
savage avengers here's the funny thing
about this though in this story
iceman becomes god he becomes a god like
it's it's kind of nuts right just like
reaching this insane level of power and
it really looks like he is he's like
this one man army right
it's just kind of nuts right we'll talk
about that once we get to it the funny
thing about this
is that what you end up having here is
conan the barbarian
who's basically thrown in jail
for those of you guys who don't know uh
the savage avengers largely focuses on
conan the barbarian with a few other
people the roster is kind of shifting
around a little bit so i wouldn't say
it's a rotating ensemble cast but at the
moment it kind of is right but he's
basically thrown in jail
because he apparently attacked a police
dog but the funny thing about this is
that
you know him being thrown in jail also
lands him in jail a deadpool because
deadpool's already there and as most of
you guys know
not the biggest deadpool fan in the
world deadpool in this story is amazing
he's hilarious and savvy's avengers uh
but the funny thing about this
is that deadpool he initially goes to
steal the keys from a cop which he's
successful in doing
ultimately he ends up stealing his
personal keys instead of the keys to
basically unlock the cell his hand is
like smashed and then when it heals
uh conan realizes oh my god this guy has
a healing factor
and so he's like your your hand heals
just like logan's does and he's like
logan yeah i know him like
i know that guy right i only ever hear
of him when he needs like some sales or
something like that right like when he
needs his comics to sell he comes and
talks to me
but uh but nonetheless he's like okay uh
logan is the guy that i want to talk to
right like i need to speak to logan
again right because
logan and conan have met previously and
kind of teamed up but not really in the
past
uh but it's one of these things where
he's kind of like okay so you heal
um what i want to do is like i want to
get basically like the claws that logan
has right like those retractable blades
and he's like snicked
so it's kind of funny to see conan
talking in his old language being
excited about like getting something
that's equivalent to
wolverine and so he's like okay so i
have a plan to get us out of here and
deadpool's like all right well what's
your plan and he's like
uh you heal right and he's like yeah
he's like cool that's what i need
because we need you to get the the keys
from the guard and the guards outside
the cell so we need to get you outside
the cell so i'm going to be as fast as i
possibly can and he basically mashes
deadpool through the bars of the prison
cell and spits them out the other side
now here's the thing if you're a guy
who's locked up in prison and you want
people to know that you're not someone
to be trifled with
squeeze them through prison bars and
people will be like okay so this guy's
obviously not to be messed with because
you know like literally all these guys
are puking their guts up one guy's like
oh my god like it's
it's pretty crazy it's kind of nuts now
of course deadpool ends up you know
basically getting out and then goes
after one of the guards
and then throws the keys to conan and
conan basically breaks them out now
that's when they're met by the arrival
of nightflyer nightflyer has existed
before uh he originally appeared back in
captain america 213 where he kind of got
into this little bit of a skirmish with
steve rogers and then was ultimately
killed not really by steve rogers but
was
basically killed in an assassination
attempt gone wrong and then ultimately
he was resurrected
and then faced off against the
incredible hulk and then was killed
again uh the reality of of having this
guy here
is that he this is one of those times
when marvel just kind of pulls out a
character
and then reworks them because they can't
right because my flyer is obscure enough
of a name
that no one's really gonna ask any
questions right like nobody reading
savage avengers right now is gonna see
nightflyer and then just be like wait
haven't i heard of him before
i guess i did right but like like aside
from like super old school characters
nobody knew
is going to ask that question so marvel
can just kind of you know create a new
night flyer and nobody's going to be any
the wiser
right so the funny thing about this
knight flyer is an amazing character
this guy stanley he's awesome and i love
i love the way that he's depicted here
so
he's like he's like you know i'm the
knight flyer like you had to have heard
of me he's like i'll lead you to it to
like basically a place where essentially
a safe house and then we'll get to a
score
and so conan's like okay like i'm
leaving uh but you know if
if you want to tell me about like the
tales of this treasure
then like i'm down with that you know
because conan's all about money and
here's the funny thing here's
here's a funny thing here right so like
as they're making their way out of here
they end up going by what is basically
the evidence stash
and uh deadpool finds the swords which
you know he's been missing for a little
while and then conan gets like a machete
and a shotgun right and he was like i'm
leaving this jail richer than when i
entered and nightflyers like that's how
you know you did jail right man
you leave better off than you were when
you went in now of course all this
coincides with the actual king and black
event so you're probably wondering like
what does any of this have to do with
the king and black so the reality is
they don't really have any intention of
facing off against null there's gonna be
this amazing moment where like where
things pop off uh
but the reality is that as they're as
they're kind of leaving
they're attacked by some of the dragons
of knoll one of them recognizes conan
and is like do you remember me remember
who i am and
basically snatches up conan and then
absorbs him right and that's what we end
up learning here that at a previous
point in time during the original city
of sickle storyline that there came a
point whereby conan quote unquote freed
the symbiote and so the way this this
kind of story is told
by this symbiote itself is that
millennia ago it had crash landed on
earth right it somehow arrived on this
world we're not really
told as to how it happened we're just
told that it did but ultimately it just
kind of changed hands where it was sold
it was stolen
it was bartered for other things until
it came in the possession of a guy who
was using the symbiote as a way to sell
other
goods right that he would basically say
like this is an ancient genie you know
if i have a genie here
imagine all the other wares and the
valuables that i have in this place of
course this is
thousands of years ago but what ends up
happening is there is a man who shows up
here
uh this simply referred to as macri raw
who's
at that point in time depicted as the
sorcerer supreme this is one of those
interesting moments where marvel
basically introduces a person
who played the role of stephen strange
before stephen strange and we know even
with like the ancient one the ancient
one's only a few thousand years old or a
few hundred years old he's not
at least he wasn't all that old in
relation to like the history of the
world and the people who existed and
that's an important distinction to
understand
when it comes to the sorcerer supreme uh
we know that there was like the original
sorcerer supreme of earth that person of
course being agamotto but as far as i'm
aware
marvel's never really given us a
chronological history of the various
sorcerer supremes who have existed
across the history of the marvel
universe right across earth we simply
kind of go with agamotto then you just
kind of
jump forward a huge number of years and
then you focus on the ancient one and
then it goes to stephen strange and
there may have been intermittent stories
where like
they're they're kind of thrown in in my
defense i'm not ultra well versed on the
history of steven strange
and all the various sorcerer supremes
that may or may not have been introduced
over the course of his of his lifespan
i'm not certain that's ever really
happened with marvel but the important
thing here you know even leaving that
out the important thing here is that
this guy
was fascinated by what he thought was a
genie now ultimately he realizes pretty
quickly while he doesn't know that it's
an actual symbiote that it's not really
a genie in the traditional sense where
it doesn't really perform magic but it
is a symbiote by all standards of
measurement right it bonds itself to
hosts different things like that
and so what ends up happening is
somewhere along the line uh this guy
is basically met by the arrival of
coulomb gath now kulon gath
is is really one of the sorcerers who
exists in marvel comics and is
essentially the arch nemesis of uh of
conan the barbarian
it's one of these things where he's
always trying to chase him down and
always trying to destroy him
uh ultimately when coulomb gath ends up
getting a hold of the symbiote and kills
the sorcerer supreme in the process
he basically subjects it to like torture
and and experimentation
all kinds of different things there's
one point where he actually tried to eat
it in order to obtain its power now a
lot of this is because at the time
coulomb gath was relatively primitive in
comparison to like people as they exist
now but ultimately what ended up
happening is that where the the symbiote
kind of
just passed from one place to the next
and then ultimately ended up in the city
of sickles
that conan when he had freed it had
basically done it a service
and so the idea is that because of
what's going on here that the the simeon
itself
harbors a vendetta against coulomb gath
and ultimately wants to to help conan
kind of achieve that goal and so it
basically reforms or has bonded itself
to conan sword
so conan can kind of use the power of
the symbiote in combination with his own
weapon and then go forward from there
now it's kind of a cool little reference
here because we know that like the first
real
revelation of null existing came by a
way of the all-black necro sword
so this is not really that it's not the
all-black necro sword as we know it but
it's a cool little tribute to the idea
of it and so what you end up getting
here is conan just kind of re-emerging
while possessing this symbiote and then
saying like telling all the little
all the dragons that are out there to
leave now most likely they did because
it was it from their perspective
it was a symbiote giving them a command
and so they ended up leaving anyway not
really because conan did it but then
deadpool's kind of like okay so like we
probably need to leave here because as
far as i'm aware
we're not really out of the range of the
snipers and then it's like pow it's a
shot and he's like
potatoes
[Laughter]
he literally got sniped in the head and
so initially they were going to leave
deadpool behind right knight flyer's
like dude leave a man and conan's like
no right he helps us to get out he's
done his part his fate will be the same
as ours right so they end up basically
racing off
and then go to what is in effect the bar
with no name and from here it's just
kind of arranging the business venture
and and getting things sorted out not a
whole lot doing there right just kind of
a
a couple of things here and there but
ultimately when they get to the location
of where the where the
the heist is going to be we find out
it's the hellfire club now the hellfire
club they've got hands in
everything but the important thing to
understand the hellfire club as it used
to exist when it was originally created
under chris claremont
doesn't really exist that way anymore
that the hellfire club and all the
various mutants involved are
essentially an extension of krakowa
right so it's kind of been reworked the
the original building itself
is more or less abandoned right there
really isn't anybody who who operates
out of there anymore all the mutants
that normally would have been here
all basically you know delve or exist in
the realm of of courcoa but the funny
thing about this
is that krakowa despite everything going
on there with the mutant population
would largely be a foolish place to keep
everything and so what they've been
doing
is all the black market money that
krakowa makes that they literally just
use this place as a slush fund and a
safe house for all the money they have
now the reality is it's also kind of a
dumb decision too i mean they've got a
gate there
but it's also kind of a dumb decision
because it's like what if somebody does
exactly what they're doing here which is
showing up here and then basically
trying to rob the joint and so when that
happens
immediately the gate opens and and like
you literally have deadpool and you've
got nightflyer and you've got conan who
are met by the arrival of callisto
um iceman and bishop now the reason why
you see these three guys here and when
the fight initially
breaks out things kind of pop off uh
it's a pretty straightforward
little skirmish here but the reason why
you see these three guys here
is because of the fact that like the
rest of the x-men as we know were sent
to fight in new york against the forces
of null and they all basically were
captured cyclops storm all those guys
were effectively captured there
and so what you get is this amazing
moment here where conan's been around
for an exceedingly long time and he's
faced off against a multitude of
different threats and as soon as he sees
iceman he's like you're not a man
you are a you're a member of the frost
giants right like you are in effect
a frost giant a godly being now iceman
has no idea who he's talking about when
he
when he tells him like you're descended
from amir the original frost giant
and and ultimately it's one of these
things where like he just attacks him
and says like tell the frost giant and
mirror they're like i'll see them in
hell right something something crazy and
kind of bonkers like that but
that's an important distinction to
understand here because for the most
part the fight ends pretty quickly
and the reason why is because there's a
timetable here and they've got more
important things to worry about
and so there is what is in effect a kind
of ceasefire in the sense that like the
mutants kind of get to
get the upper hand but it's really more
of like okay like cool our horses right
like
let's cool our jets find out what's
going on and it's really just just
callisto and bishop and iceman saying
look like you know we're leading the
x-men now because
all the other ones are basically
captured you know in the fight against
noel so
ultimately they're like you know we can
let you guys go and we can you know we
can all team up and face off against
null or we can we can just take you guys
back to gracoa and then whatever fate
resides you or whatever fate you know
goes on there we can just kill you
whatever it is so they kind of force
their hand and so ultimately the group
more or less teams up right and they
they end up going to face off against
the forces of null now
here's the cool thing that happens here
as soon as they arrive there you
immediately have cyclops who shows up
right or it really just kind of appears
and when they try to talk him down of
course the control
that null has over psychos because he's
not one of the one of the individuals
who was freed by dylan
it's really just too strong and so
there's no way they can just kind of
talk him down
from being who he is right from from
being possessed by null the other crazy
thing that happens
is storm enters the fray now the funny
thing is that callisto realizes
storms there and then she's looking at
deadpool who has two swords and she's
like you
idiot you're holding lightning rods like
she kicks him out of the way
her nephew gets electrocuted by storm so
she's like get away from me
and so storm shows up but you also get
this amazing moment here where null
basically establishes
that storm's the most powerful host he
has right he says of all my new avatars
this one is the most powerful here's the
thing to understand guys a lot of folks
are sleeping on storm they see her as
like a girl who manipulates weather
here's
here's the important thing to understand
while storm has more recently been
established to be an omega level mutant
under jonathan hickman
even before that we all basically knew
she was i mean there is a kind of
like definitive statement storm is omega
level when marvel confirms it but like
you can oftentimes look at a mutant and
just know that they basically are you
know the the designation of a character
being omega level by marvel comics
is really more just an official status
but you just kind of have to look at
what they're capable of right like look
at the full gamut the weakest points of
their powers and the highest points of
their powers and just kind of make a
differentiation from there uh but the
the cool thing about this
is that you end up having conan talking
directly to iceman here because of
everything going down they're like okay
the mission is scrubbed right we gotta
go like we we are in no position
to take these guys on they're way beyond
us and that's when conan's like look i
know you don't you've never heard of
amir
you don't believe you're a frost giant
but understand like you are not a man
right i mean
sure there's some mutant you know mutant
kind going on there but you have the
blood of frost giants in you
and the frost giants i know are superly
overpowered right these guys are insane
so literally iceman is just like okay
cool let's do this amps up the full
totality of his power right like the
full brunt of his power
just like amplifies it all becomes like
this godly level character right like
when they're like okay ice man we gotta
go and conan's like no man like you need
to fight like you're a frost giant right
like you've got frost giant blood in
your veins you've got the blood of gods
in your veins
it's time to start acting like it then
like like literally
uh bishop is like ice man we gotta go
and iceman's like nope we're staying
here like i'm staying here and i'm
fighting this and it's it's
nuts right the way that it's described
here is they say like for the first time
in recorded history new york became the
coldest place on the planet like
literally channels the full totality of
his power
and takes on every single one of these
symbiote dragons and it's not like
there's two
i mean there's something like eight or
nine of these things now keep in mind
these dragons were a handful for even
like
thor or somebody out there who was who
was struggling to take them on iceman
just
increases his size several times over
and literally just
and it's just it's crazy to see we've
never really seen iceman do this the
only time
we ever saw iceman kind of elevate
himself to this level is when
uh when emma frost took control of his
body and then was like oh my god this
guy's omega level right like it's just
it's ice man at his most it really at
the highest we've ever seen him and
here's a crazy thing about this it's not
even at his most extreme but the
the the possibility being here and we
don't know if it's actually true right
it's just a statement by jerry dugan it
might be something they explore later on
but if iceman really is
really does have frost giant blood in
his body then iceman
really is a god like he really is
descended from gods which would explain
why his power
is so extreme but only ever appears in
small moments because he just never
pushes it to that extreme but the crazy
thing is that you end up having the rest
of the characters the rest of
the savage avengers as they exist along
with the x-men kind of going back to the
safe house while iceman's still fighting
this fight and when that happens it's
just kind of like okay
like we need to kind of get back out
there but ultimately conan's like i
still want to speak with logan right so
logan of course
shows up here and meets with conan and
and it's kind of like okay like like
what did you want to talk to me about
right like what what did you want me for
he's like no i'm just here out of
respect
i wanted you to know this place is now
mine right this this base for the
hellfire club
this is now my house right i'm taking
this place over this is gonna be my base
of operations we're gonna operate out of
here right
formally it was controlled by your guys
but no more and if anybody has any
questions about that then let them know
what i'm capable of and let them know to
expect
a massive fight when they get here and
so it's like i'm just letting you know
right this is like i am the new king
here so it's an interesting thing
because it's really more of just kind of
jerry dugan
doing this for the purpose of just being
like here's conan's new base of
operations but something else to
understand here
conan's going forward with the
possession of a symbiote like conan is
going to have a symbiote as part of his
weapons cache so like that's really
going to change and elevate his power i
gotta say guys
i'm digging this savage avengers story
right this is pretty solid like i'm
definitely i'm definitely into this so
uh i think i'll probably start reading
it more
from from here on out but let me know
what you guys think right let me know
how you guys feel about this if you guys
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you